speaking of that search of the former
president's florida home it has angered
many of his supporters including a man
who tried to force his way into a fbi
field office in cincinnati yesterday
police say the man was armed after a car
chase he was shot and killed social
media posts thought to be from the
suspect show he may have been motivated
by the search of mar-a-lago senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge has more
the situation began around 9 a.m
thursday when the suspect wearing body
armor and carrying a nail gun and long
gun tried to breach the fbi's visitor
screening center in cincinnati sources
tell cbs news the suspect is ricky
schiffer the fbi says agents confronted
the suspect before he fled leading to a
car chase the pursuit came in and he
stopped his vehicle
when he got out that's when shots were
exchanged between officers and the
suspect after an hours long standoff law
enforcement officials say they shot and
killed the suspect situations like today
are unfortunate they're unfortunate for
a community they're unfortunate for
those involved in it after the fbi
searched donald trump's mar-a-lago home
monday posts believed to be from the
suspect encouraged people to go to palm
beach where trump's estate is located
and kill federal agents if they get in
the way additional posts that appear to
be from the same man claim he was at
then president trump's january 6 speech
on the ellipse we fight like hell and if
you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore and
later at the capitol as the riots
unfolded thursday morning a user with
the same name as the suspect posted if
you don't hear from me it is true i
tried attacking the fbi earlier this
week fbi director christopher wray
condemned calls for violence against
bureau agents any threats made against
law enforcement including the men and
women of the fbi are deplorable
and dangerous for cbs morning's i'm
katherine herridge in washington